[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros y
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia doctor gracias por
acompañarnos en reino unido se ha
comenzado a utilizar el término long
cobit para definir al impacto duradero
de la infección por corona virus de qué
se trata cuáles son estos síntomas
es importante saber que estamos
conociendo la enfermedad lo que hemos lo
que se ha mostrado actualmente es que
hay algunas personas no son todas son
algunas personas que tienen unos
síntomas que se prolongan en el tiempo
ya sean por secuelas por su atención por
la enfermedad de base o porque tienen
algunas complicaciones derivadas del
code y eso es lo que se ha llamado lonko
beat estamos evaluando la información
para saber qué personas y cómo actuar
con esp que con ese grupo de personas
como digo la mayoría de personal no van
a resolver y esto es en un grupo de
personas que puede suceder pues como nos
identifica doctor se está evaluando
apenas esta situación y frente a este
impacto todavía poco claro existen
formas para tratar las secuelas que deje
el comité en las personas
si se están evaluando bastantes formas
están haciendo unas unidades de análisis
de estos pacientes post cover en donde
varias especialidades neumólogos
reumatólogos inmunólogos infectólogos se
reúnen y empiezan a evaluar qué
características tiene la lesión como se
puede enfrentar y de qué forma lo
podemos hacer a través de rehabilitación
a través de manejo analgésico a través
del manejo antiinflamatorio en este
momento estamos ante esa nueva desafío
que nos presenta que es esta
persistencia de los síntomas y para eso
digamos los grupos médicos ya nos
estamos preparando estamos evaluando la
información para poder actuar un poco
mejor antes otra de las advertencias del
instituto nacional de investigación en
salud de reino unido doctor es que las
personas diagnosticadas con síntomas
debes de kobe 19 o incluso sin haber
sido diagnosticadas luego presentan
síntomas más severos con el tiempo por
qué ocurre esto y qué hacer ante ello
es digamos un fragmento de personal
donde se puede dar una respuesta
paradójica de la enfermedad lo que hemos
sabido es que generalmente esta
enfermedad primera semana se resuelve
solo
algunas personas tienen complicaciones
en la segunda semana de la enfermedad y
hay algunos pequeños casos que han
tenido complicaciones por los fenómenos
embólicos algún tipo de estos fenómenos
y que puede suceder después y que puedan
ser atribuibles a la infección por todo
enfermedades también neurológicas como
la miel y después enfermedades
vasculares o miocárdicas que nos de no
se afronta eso al reto de prevenir
primero que en la gente no se enferme
para la gente que se enferme
hacer un seguimiento para poder evaluar
qué personas pueden tener eventualmente
esta complicación y por ahora lo mejor
es no contagiarse que registro se tienen
en la región de américa latina de este
loco beat doctor o qué información hay
en la región
creo que de esta ahora estamos pasando
la fase de picos distinto a lo que ha
pasado al reino unido donde ya están en
el rebrote que han tenido mayor
información en américa latina tenemos
ese desafío actual de recoger la
información de crear estas unidades de
análisis hay grupos de especialistas que
ya se están reuniendo para poder haberlo
evaluar los pacientes en las juntas
multidisciplinarias y dar directrices
sobre el manejo de los pacientes es la
hora que nuestra región se prepara en
los grupos médicos para ser unidades
post kobe para evaluar estos pacientes
no evitar que los pacientes sean vistos
por diferentes especialistas sino que
vayan a un solo sitio para que sea
manejo único y uniforme y podamos
también responder de esa forma a este
nuevo reto que nos marca la pandemia
doctor díaz se conocen casos de personas
que se vuelven a contagiar del cob y 19
porque de qué depende esto
son pocos casos el que se llama
reinfección para demostrar que ahorre
una reinfección tienen que ser dos
linajes de virus distintos no dos
pruebas de pcr positivas sino dos
linajes de virus hay algunos casos uno
de estos casos tuvo un desenlace fatal
pero una persona que tenía muchas
comorbilidades y alguna otra persona
también tuvo requerimiento oxígeno eso
qué significa significa que en algún
grupo de personas de inmensa minoría
pueda ser nuevamente infección
generalmente después de cuatro o cinco
meses podría ser no sabemos a qué grupo
de personas y por eso no se pueden pedir
las perder las medidas de bioseguridad
en personas que ya han sido ya
infectadas para el coi que esto no es un
limitación para que salgamos para que
nos salgamos de nuestras casas no
olvidemos hagamos todo el esfuerzo para
hacer la activación económica pero
siempre recién establemente
independientemente que seamos bien ha
resuelto el corte muy bien pues muchas
gracias doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia y gracias a ustedes
siga con más mucho más en francés
[Música]